Oh
if you had the chance to play the Ghost
Recon wildlands beta this weekend you
probably found plenty of things you
liked and other things you didn't like
here are some things we'd like to see
added or fixed before the game launches
on march seven and if you didn't get a
chance to play the beta or you're still
on the fence about this one make sure to
hit that subscribe button so you'll be
the first to know when our review drops
next month number one alternative
chopper controls helicopters and planes
are the most efficient way of getting
around the map unfortunately flying
around in one of these birds doesn't
feel all that great your helicopter
should maintain momentum as you soar
through the skies however instead of a
smooth trip from point A to B the whole
experience felt a bit jerky when I
finally did slow down to land or to
hover it felt like the chopper was
fighting against me every step of the
way also why are there no crosshairs on
the helicopters with guns how is anyone
supposed to aim this to improve squad
commands Ghost Recon wildlands seems to
be missing a lot of squad commands that
we've come to expect in a ghost recon
game stay there especially for those of
us who don't want to play co-op I get
that this is an effort to streamline the
experience but when would I ever want my
squad to march into a hostile base
without me giving the okay first let me
set waypoints for my AI squad mates and
give me the option to tell them to stay
in the Humvee and cover me from a
mounted minigun when I want them to
number three improved no HUD mode my
favorite way to play The Ghost Recon
wildlands beta was with the HUD turned
off I found this to be way more
immersive it forced me to pay closer
attention to my surroundings and listen
to the chatter between my squad mates
and enemies
tango school start locals unfortunately
getting anywhere without a HUD is almost
impossible without constantly checking
the map in the menus I would love it if
my ghost had an in-game compass or map
that I could check similar to what we
saw in Far Cry 2 number 40 Inge sniper
rifles one cool addition to Ghost Recon
wildlands is bullet drop for long-range
firearms target down in the beta there
was a rangefinder but I wasn't able to
zero in my scopes if you're going to add
bullet drop in a tactical shooter why
not take that extra step and let us plan
the perfect shot by adding a sniper
spotter mechanic number five more
destruction I think it's probably a bit
too late to expect a destruction engine
similar to what we saw in battlefield
one but I can't tell you how many times
I drove into small trees are fences
expecting them to break and they didn't
or if they did my car would slam to a
halt first it was really annoying I'd
love it if the destruction was taken one
step further and allowed us to level
watchtowers it seems like a bit of a
stretch but right now the only way to
deal with snipers and towers is by
counter sniping them a little more
variety would be nice Ghost Recon
wildlands is out in a few weeks let me
know what you thought of the beta in the
comments below and what you think needs
to be changed or added if you want to
see more Ghost Recon wildlands check out
our no HUD gameplay and don't forget to
subscribe thanks for watching
interrogate hostile lieutenants talk to
civvies whatever it takes we'll turn
over every Rock
you
you